The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's get started.
We want to first review Wald's
equality a little bit.
Wald's equality is very
tricky thing.
If you think you understand
it, you will go along.
And at some point, you will be
using it and you will say, I
don't understand
what this says.
And that will happen
for a long time.
It still happens to
me occasionally.
What happens is you
work with it for
longer and longer times.
The periods when it becomes
confusing become rarer.
And the expected time
to straighten
it out becomes smaller.
It is a strange kind
of result.
So we started out with a
stopping trial definition.
J is a stopping trial for a
sequence of random variables.
If it's a random variable and
it has the property that for
each n greater than or equal
to 1, the indicator random
variable indicator of J
equals n is a function
of X1 to X sub n.
In other words, the decision of
whether to stop at time n
is a function of 1 up to n.
A possibly effective stopping
trial is the same, except that
might be a defective
random variable.
And the reason you want to have
possibly defective random
variables is that before you
start analyzing something that
might be a stopping rule, you
generally have no way of
knowing whether that actually is
a stopping rule or whether
it's a detective
stopping rule.
So you might as well just say
it's a defective stopping rule
to start with and show
that it's not.
Then from that, we went on to
Wald's equality which added
the condition that X sub n that
this is based on is a
sequence of IID random
variables.
To be a stopping trial,
you don't
need IID random variables.
You don't need any restriction
at all, other than the fact
that you can make a decision on
when to stop based on what
you've already seen.
That's the only condition
there.
Wald's equality is based on this
extra condition that the
random variables are IID.
Each of them, with
some mean, X bar.
If J is a stopping trial and as
the expected value of J is
less than infinity, then the
sum S sub J at the stopping
trial, J, satisfies this
relationship here.
And remember we proved
that last time.
And the key to proving it,
the hard part of it--
well, it's not hard
if you see it.
But what's difficult is when you
start looking at how you
find the expected value of S
sub J that's equal to a sum
over n of X sub n times the
indicator function of J being
greater than or equal to n.
Now the condition here is that
this indicator at J equals n
is a function of these
quantities here.
When you add the IID quantity
down here, what you find then
is the indicator function for J
greater than or equal to n.
It's also the indicator function
for J 1 minus the
indicator function for
J less than n.
It's independent of X1 up to
X sub blah, blah, blah.
That indicator random variable
is then a function only of X1
up to X sub n minus 1, because
it's 1 minus the indicator of
J less than or equal
to n minus 1.
J less than n, which means that
X1 up to X n minus 1 is
independent of Xn.
And X1 up to X n minus 1 is what
determines this indicator
function J less than n.
It's the J less than n
which is important.
So we got that Wald's
equality.
What I want to do today to start
off with is to do the
elementary renewal theorem,
which is a strange result.
Wald's equality, you can use it
to determine the expected
value of N of t.
Now why do we want to determine
the expected
value of N of t?
We already have shown in great
generality that there's a very
nice, with probability, one type
limit theorem associated
with N of t over t.
We know that N of t over
t approaches t
with probability 1.
Namely, all the sample
functions, except a set of
probability 0, all approach
this same
constant, 1 over X bar.
So it seems that we know
everything we want to know
about the expected value of
N of t, about N of t, and
everything else.
But no.
And there are two reasons
why you want to do
something more than that.
One of them is that very often
you want to know how N of t
over t approaches the limit
of 1 over X bar.
The other is that sometimes you
really are interested in,
what is N of t at some
finite value of t?
N of t is a random variable,
some finite value of t.
So you can't evaluate it.
But at least you would
like to know what its
expected value is.
You might want to know what
it's variance is too.
But people who study renewal
theory have spent an enormous
amount of time on trying
to find the expected
value of N of t.
It's the basic problem that
people work on all the time.
The elementary renewal theorem
is something which says a
little more for finite times.
And it actually says the
expected value of N of t over
t and the limit is equal
to 1 over X bar.
Sounds like much less than
what we've done before.
And perhaps this is because this
was a computational thing
that people could do without
computers, before computers
came along.
And all the work on renewal
theory went on basically from
1900 until about 1970.
People didn't have any computers
to compute things.
And all the mathematicians who
were interested in this field
really loved to compute
ugly things.
And they computed ugly
things all the time.
And the expected value of N of
t was one of the ugly things
that they could really
do a lot with.
So it probably has more
importance in this field than
it deserves.
But it does have some
importance.
Anyway, what we want to do is
to get some idea of why this
elementary renewal
theorem is true.
Later on we will study how to
actually find the expected
value of N of t.
N of t is the number of arrivals
that have occurred up
to and including t.
So N of t plus 1 is the
number of the first
arrival after t since--
that should be a t there--
the expected value of N of t is
finite, the expected value
J is also finite.
In other words, we're defining
J to be N of t plus 1.
We want to show the J is
actually a stopping trial.
And therefore we can use
Wald's equality on it.
Let's stop and think
for a minute.
Why don't we just define a
stopping trial to be the
number of arrivals that have
occurred up until time t?
What's the matter with that?
If I let you observe a sequence
of these IID random
variables, the first
inter-arrival interval, the
second inter-arrival interval,
the third inter-arrival
interval, and so forth, and I
say stop when you have the
last dozen that's less than t.
The question is, is that
a stopping trial?
You have to be able to determine
that just from what
you've seen up until
the present.
But when you see that last
arrival, there's no way you
know that it's the last arrival
less than t unless you
see the arrival after that,
also to see whether that's
greater than t.
So the only way you can define
a stopping trial of this form
is to define the stopping trial
not at N of t, but of N
of t plus 1.
So now we want to apply Wald's
equality to the expected value
of the time at which N
of t plus 1 arises.
Do you see now why we want to
call this a stopping trial
instead of a stopping time?
If you call that a stopping
time, you want to know what
you were doing at this point.
Because the stopping trial says
you're looking at the
first arrival that occurs
after time t.
Then you're looking at
the time at which
that arrival occurs.
Wald's equality says the
expected value of that time is
equal to the expected value of
the inter-arrival time times
the expected value of J.
J is a stopping trial.
The expected value
of J is just--
J is N of t plus 1.
So that's expected value of
N of t plus 1 times X bar.
That's simple.
It's simple until you try to
recreate that argument.
I would suggest to all of you
that sometime later today you
go back and try to recreate
this argument.
And if you can do it, then
you understand it.
If you can't, think about
it a little more.
Because it is deceptively
simple.
So that was a relationship
we had.
Wald's equality then is
relating two unknown
quantities.
It's relating the expected
value of N of t with the
expected value of the first
arrival time after t.
That's one of the troubles
with Wald's equality.
It relates two things that,
neither of which you know in
many cases.
There are many situations
in which you do
know one or the other.
We talked about one last time.
But in most of them, you don't
know either of them.
So it doesn't help
you immediately.
You have to find
something else.
So what we're going to do here
is say, well we can't find
expected value of N
of t from this.
But we can at least bound it.
And we can bound it by saying
that S sub N of t plus 1.
This is the time of the
first arrival after t.
The first arrival after t has
to be at a time greater than
or equal to t.
So expected value of S sub N
of t plus 1 also is greater
than or equal to t.
So expected value of N of t,
solving this equation is
expected value of S sub N of t
plus 1 over X bar minus 1.
And then you lower bound
expected value of this first
arrival after t by t.
So the expected value of N of
t has to be greater than t
over X bar minus 1.
Well this seems to be useful,
because if what you're
interested in is the expected
value of N of t over t.
And that's what we're interested
in for the
elementary renewal theorem.
You're saying that that's
greater than 1 over X bar
minus 1 over t.
And when t gets large, that 1
over t term gets very small.
What that means is you have a
lower bound on expected value
of N of t, which is going
to 1 over X bar.
The elementary renewal theorem
then says, let X bar be the
mean inter-renewal.
Then the limit of t approaches
infinity of the expected value
of N of t over t is equal
to 1 over X bar.
Very weak result.
At least it seems to be
a very weak result.
But we need an upper bound on
the expected value of N of t.
We don't have any upper bound
on this quantity here.
Because you remember these--
Actually S sub N of t plus 1
minus t is this residual
life at time t.
And we found that the residual
life at time t can be pretty
badly behaved.
So we're in trouble.
So what do we do?
Well the argument is done
carefully in the notes.
It's very discouraging to me,
because this should be a
simple result.
And here this argument
is incredibly tricky.
So we're working very hard to
do something that's not--
Well, it seems like it ought
to be elementary.
It is an elementary result in
terms of its usefulness.
It's a very hard result in terms
of trying to prove it.
So the way you prove this is
first you truncate the random
variable X. Namely instead of
having a random variable with
this arbitrary, non-negative
probability distribution, what
you do is you look at another
random variable, which has the
same distribution up until some
large value B. And then
you truncate it at that point.
So the distribution function
looks like--
Here's f of x, however
it might look.
This is 1 here.
This is supposed to be
going up towards 1.
And what you do is you truncate
it at some point B.
So this is a truncated version
which stops at B. And this
here is the actual Fx of x.
So first you truncate
the random variable.
Then you prove the elementary
renewal theorem for that
truncated random variable,
which is easy.
Because at that point, the
expected value of S sub N of t
plus 1 is less than or
equal to t plus B.
And then the next thing you have
to do is monkey around
with the difference between
X bar and X tilde bar.
And you have to go through a
bunch of strange inequalities.
You have to then let B approach
infinity as t is
approaching infinity in
just the right way.
And when you get all of done
doing this, bingo.
You get the elementary
renewal theorem.
You see why I don't want to
go through that in class.
And you see, I hope, why
probably most of you will not
want to go through it
in detail either.
Because if you want to learn
how to do truncation
arguments, this is probably not
the best one to use as a
way of figuring out
how to do that.
If you want to learn how to use
truncation arguments, do
the Weak law of large
numbers where you
don't have a variance.
It's done back in chapter one.
It's a nice relatively simple
argument where you truncate a
random variable.
This one is just peculiar.
We do all of that with stopping
trials as we've
defined them.
Very often, and particularly
when you get to queuing
theory, you want to define
stopping trials in a more
general way.
And here's a more general
definition.
A generalized stopping trial
for a sequence of pairs of
random variables, X1, V1, X2,
V2, X3, V3, is a positive
integer random variable such as
for each n greater than or
equal to 1, the indicator
function, which tells you
whether to stop or not, is
a function of X1, V1, X2,
V2, up to Xn, Vn.
In other words, you don't have
to decide whether to stop or
not in terms of these random
variables X1 to Xn that you're
interested in.
You have this other set of
random variables too.
Typically in queuing situations,
these other random
variables that you're
interested
in are service times.
And the X's are arrival times.
And these things are going on
in parallel with each other.
And still, you can do the same
arguments about stopping
trials by looking at just the
past history of the input
random variables and these
other random variables,
whatever they happen to be.
Wald's equality then says that
the expected value of S sub n
is equal to X bar times the
expected value J, where Sn is
the sum of the X's.
And Wald's equality holds
by exactly the
same proof as before.
There's nothing new.
You just look at the proof
and you say, OK.
All these V's are involved
there also.
You can replace each of Vi in
this definition with a whole
vector of random variable.
So you can make this
as general as you
want to make it.
In fact, a lot of people prove
Wald's equality by skipping
all of this stuff about
stopping trials.
And what they say is that the
rule for stopping at time J is
independent of all of
the future arrivals.
And that lets you prove the
theorem immediately.
It doesn't give you any clue at
all as to when that holds,
so that in fact you're taking
Wald's equality and making it
essentially a truism.
And you're avoiding the real
problem, which is to know when
you have a stopping rule
and when you don't
have a stopping rule.
But anyway, we can generalize
it in this way.
And now we want to use this to
look at a fairly general
queueing situation.
We talked about the G/G/M
queue before.
Let's just talk about the G/G/1
queue at this point.
This is a queue with general
independent IID and her
arrival times, IID
service times.
So what you wind up with is
at time 0, you assume that
there's an arrival at time 0.
You don't count it as part of
the arrival renewal process.
So this arrival is here.
That arrival goes
into service.
There's some service
time V sub 0.
At some inter-arrival time, X1,
another arrival comes in.
In this particular sample
function here, the second
arrival comes in before this 0
arrival that we didn't account
finishes service.
And I'm sorry.
I should have--
It might make better sense to
call this X1 and call this V1.
It would make all the
notation simpler.
Or call this X0 and
call this V0.
But unfortunately that's not
consistent with any of the
notation that anybody
uses for talking
about renewal processes.
Because you want these X's
to be the elements
of a renewal process.
You want the V's to be
IID random variables.
And this, unfortunately, is
the way it has to be.
So these arrivals come in.
This is the inter-arrival
time before--
This is S1 here, which is
the time of the first
arrival after 0.
This is S2, which is the
time of the first
arrival after time 0.
And when you count the arrival
at time 0 in, this function
here is N of t plus 1.
So this is N of t plus
1 going along here.
This is the arrival process
plus 1, where now we've
counted this arrival
at time 0.
You have these services
going on.
V0 for this particular sample
function is the time of the
service of this 0 arrival.
V1 is the time of the
service of this X1--
well, it's the service time of
the arrival that has come in
at this point.
This is the service time of
the arrival at time 0.
the arrival at this time.
This as the service time
of the arrival at
this time and so forth.
I want to make sure that you
understand this model here
before we go on.
Because if you don't understand
this, you won't
understand anything
we do after this.
If you look at this now, you see
a departure process which
is going on also.
These departure times are
determined partly as a sum of
the number of customers to
have departed by time t.
And this example here is just
the sum of V0 plus V1 plus V2.
So it's almost the same as this
renewal process here,
except here you're talking about
a renewal process of
dealing with the departure
times.
This changes any time that
the queue empties out.
Because when the queue empties
out, the server isn't doing
anything for a while.
So suddenly, the number of
departures slows up.
And in some sense, you
reset things here.
What I want to do in this
argument today is to explain
much more carefully why you can
actually restart things
when this new arrival occurs.
So I want to say that, in fact,
this is a renewal time
for this entire queuing
process.
These are renewal times
for the arrivals
to the queuing process.
This thing here, the next
arrival to an empty server and
so forth, are all, in fact,
renewals of the
entire queuing system.
We want to understand
why that is.
We want to use this idea
of stopping trials
to understand this.
So look at the first arrival
to start a new busy period.
Well, think of that as a
generalized stopping trial.
Why is it generalized
stopping trial?
Well the sequence of paired
random variables we want to
look at is X1, V0, X2, V1,
X3, V2, and so forth.
And stopping at J equals 3 is
actually a function of this
first pair, the second pair, and
the third pair, which is
the restriction we need
for a stopping trial.
So the stopping trial stop when
the first arrival comes
to an empty system is in fact a
function of the arrivals and
as the departure intervals
up until that time.
Wald's equality holds because,
in fact, every time you get a
new arrival, it's independent
of all the old arrivals.
It's independent of all
the old service times.
the new service
times also, sort of.
But you have to be more
careful with that.
But in fact, the service
times are all IID.
So that works too.
So Wald's equality holds here.
But that's not what we're
interested in here.
What we're interested in is
trying to show that you do get
renewals at these times here.
So let's try to argue
why that is.
Did I--
AUDIENCE: Question?
Do V's have to be independent
somehow?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Do the V's have to
be independent somehow?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So they have to be
independent from one another?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It was the case
here, you said.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's what you mean
by a G/G/1 queue.
A G/G/1 queue is--
AUDIENCE: You have a service
time and the arrival.
PROFESSOR: Service time.
AUDIENCE: They're both
independent.
PROFESSOR: They're both
independent, yes.
AUDIENCE: And that makes
the departure?
PROFESSOR: Right.
And in fact, the first G says
that the arrivals are IID,
have an arbitrary
distribution.
The second G says that the
service times are IID, but
have an arbitrary
distribution.
And then the 1, our the M, or
whatever, says how many
servers there are.
AUDIENCE: And that makes the
departures independent?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you can really have much
more general queuing
situations than this.
And you often do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: With the departure
process, it's not a renewal?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: The departures.
PROFESSOR: The departure process
is not a renewal
process, because every
once in while, the
server stops doing anything.
What?
AUDIENCE: That's how I got
confused actually.
Because every once in a while,
the server somehow--
PROFESSOR: Every once
in a while, the
server stops working.
But V1, V2, V3 are defined
as the service time
of the first customer.
Well actually V0, the service
time of the zeroth customer.
V1 is the service time of
the first customer.
Namely the time from when the
customer enters service to
when the customer's finished
with service.
And the reason why
these things--
If you looked at the sequence
V0, V1, V2, V3, you could call
that a renewal process.
But it wouldn't be a renewal
process of any interest to
you, because it would be a
renewal process where the
renewals occur at V0,
at V0 plus V1, at V0
plus V1 plus V2.
And those might not be the time
when these customers are
finishing service.
Because there are these
idle times to take
into account also.
If you didn't have the ideal
times to take into account,
you wouldn't have to think about
queuing theory at all.
Because all you'd have is two
separate and independent
renewal processes.
So this is where all of the
gimmickry in all of queuing
theory comes from.
But what I wanted to come back
and say that I didn't say very
well before.
In the notes, the assumption
is that these
pairs here are IID.
What you really would like is
something a little more
general than that, which says
that each Xi is independent of
all of the earlier pairs.
So that that's giving you a
little bit of flexibility for
how these other random
variables impact the situation.
And in fact, they can be
anything at all, just so long
as you have this condition that
each Xi is independent of
all these past things here.
So we said that Wald's
equality holds.
But the other thing, which is
what we really want, is the
new arrivals.
Namely the arrival after S3,
which comes at S3 plus X3.
That's X sub J plus 1, X sub
J plus 2, and so forth.
And the service times, in this
case V sub J, is the service
time that occurs after this.
V sub J plus 1, and so forth,
are all independent of the old
arrivals and the old
service times.
So in fact, this is actually
saying that everything that
happens after this J's arrival
is independent of everything
that happens before.
And when I say everything, you
have to be careful about that,
because we're talking about all
the inter-arrival times
that occur after this.
And we're talking about all of
the service times that occur
after this.
We're not talking about things
like S sub n plus 1, which is
the time of the next arrival,
because that's this arrival
time plus that next
inter-arrival time.
So each of these intervals
are in fact
independent of each other.
And what we've done here is use
this idea of a stopping
trial not to define when we stop
this whole process, but
to define when a
renewal occurs.
In other words, we're using
it to define when the old
inter-renewal period ends
and a new one begins.
This can be called a stopping
trial, if in fact you stop the
whole process at that
point and then
don't do anything further.
So that's what's nice about this
idea of stopping trials.
They let you not only
do Wald's equality.
But they also let you actually
see why it is that these
arrivals that start after this
point are independent of the
arrivals and departures
before that.
So let me just try to
say that again.
The stopping rule is the index
of the first arrival in a new
busy period.
The arrivals and departures
in the new busy period are
independent and identically
distributed to
those in the old.
Thus the intervals between
new busy periods
form a renewal process.
And that's the thing that
we're going to use in
everything else we do here.
So we have one renewal process,
which is embedded in
another renewable process.
The outside renewal process of
the arrivals are what you
start out with.
These embedded renewals are, in
fact, functions of both the
arrival process and the
service distribution.
So that's a more complicated
thing.
But at least you now know that
that's an arrival process.
It says that you can analyze
any one of these queuing
systems or any considerably
broader type of queueing
system, which has the same
property of having renewals
every once in a while, by
looking at what happens within
a renewal period.
Then using what happens within
a renewal period and applying
one of these limit theorems on
the embedded renewals to get
some time average
overall time.
So that's what we're
really up to here.
This same analysis
applies to G/G/m.
Applies to lots of
queueing systems.
You have to look at a
queuing system and
see whether it applies.
To get some idea of how you
can see that without going
through this whole analysis,
suppose that you decided to
try to call this point here,
at which the system first
became empty the end of
a renewal period.
Why couldn't you do that?
Why is this not a
renewal period?
Well, is it a stopping trial?
It certainly isn't a stopping
trial for the X's.
Because at this time when this
last departure has left, you
have no idea how long this new
inter-arrival period that's
going on here is going to be.
That has some arbitrary
distribution.
All we know at this point is
that it's longer than this.
And if you had a busy period end
at some point close to the
beginning of this inter-arrival
period, you have
a different distribution from
when it occurs close to the
end of an inter-arrival
period.
Well, because these
inter-arrivals are not
memoryless.
They have memory which says
their conditional distribution
depends on how long they've
been running.
So this is the only sensible
place you can define a renewal
process here.
So let's go on.
There is something called
Little's theorem, which was
invented by John Little
not all that long ago.
And Little's theorem is curious,
because you can view
it as being either trivial
or non-trivial.
I will try to convince you that
it's trivial and also
convince you that it's
non-trivial.
And what I mean by that is that
it's trivial in terms of
trying to use it someplace.
It's then nontrivial to try
to justify that you
can actually do that.
But you get the idea of doing
it in many, many places.
We're going to assume an arrival
at time 0, like we've
been doing before.
Service process can be
almost anything.
But let's assume a G/G/1
queue to be specific.
The system empties out
eventually with probability 1.
And assume that it restarts
on the next arrival.
We've seen that intervals
between restarting form a
renewal process for
the G/G/1 queue.
And we've argued that it forms
a renewal process for an even
broader class of queues.
That's normally.
Who can tell me when you don't
get a renewal process when you
have a G/G/1 queue?
We made an assumption
here without talking
at all about it.
And what's that assumption?
What?
AUDIENCE: Starting with
an empty queue.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Every once in a while, you
get an empty queue.
If you have a system where
service times are greater than
inter-arrival times, what's
going to happen is that
arrivals keep coming
in, eventually
building up more and more.
The queue gets longer
and longer.
And you never have any
renewals occurring.
So one thing we didn't say here
is we're talking about
G/G/1 queues and more general
queues, and the more important
case where the queue sometimes
empty out.
We want to use this to
analyze when they
actually do empty out.
So here's the picture.
The same kind of picture as
before of an arrival process.
And every time we're talking
about these kinds of things,
these queuing situations, we
will distinguish the arrival
process, which is a
renewal process.
But when we talk about the
renewal process, we'll talk
about this renewal process which
starts on arrivals to an
empty system.
So here's a renewal.
Here's a renewal,
and so forth.
Suppose we look at the
difference between A
of t and D of t.
A of t is the number of arrivals
that have come in up
until time t, counting this
arrival at time 0.
D of t is the number of
departures that have occurred.
What is the difference?
The difference, L of t, is the
number of customers in the
system at time t.
And one of the things you'd like
to be able to analyze in
a queuing system is, what's
the distribution?
What do you know about how
busy the queue is?
If you build storage for 100
customers, you would like to
know what's the likelihood
that that
storage will fill up.
And you have to drop customers
on the floor or do whatever
you do to customers when
the queue is full.
So L of t is clearly something
we want to look at.
It's the number of customers
in the system at any time.
Not the number of customers
waiting in queue, but the
number of customers both to
waiting in queue and being
served currently.
We can view this as a
generalized renewal reward
function at this point, because
this number in the
system at any given time t, is a
function what happens within
this inter-renewal
period here.
It's a function of these
arrivals within this
inter-renewal period and these
departures within this
inter-renewal period.
So we can use renewal
reward theory.
The total reward with an inner
renewal period is the integral
of L of tau over that period.
This is the way we found--
Every time we looked at renewal
reward theory, we
looked at the reward within
one inter-renewal period.
And then we tried to look at
what happened when we started
to look at many, many
inter-renewal periods.
So we want to look at
L of tau integrated
over one renewal period.
And then we want to go on to
see how we apply renewal
theory over that.
So in each inter-renewal period,
the aggregate number
and queue number in the system
integrated over the duration
of that inter-renewal period is
this integral of L of tau.
Here I've stated Little's
theorem really.
Let's go back and see where
that comes from.
If I want to look at the
integral of L of t over this
period of time, what is it?
I can view it as W1
plus W2 plus W3.
That's the easy way to integrate
this function.
You start out here.
You're integrating up to here.
1 times D tau.
And you have 2 times D tau.
Then 1, then 2, and
then 1 again.
But the easy way to integrate it
is just say the integral is
W1 plus W2 times this
height, plus W3.
For those of you who have
studied Lebesgue integration,
it's the idea of a Lebesgue
integral as opposed to a
Riemann integral.
If you haven't studied it,
don't worry about it.
It's just a trivial idea that
you can integrate this way as
well as integrating this way.
That's the crux of
Little's theorem.
The crux of Little's theorem is
this equality between the
integral of L of t and the
sum of the waiting
times of each customer.
W1 is the waiting time
of customer--
Well it's the waiting time of
customer 0 in this case.
W2 is the waiting time of
customer 1, from the time it
comes in, it's waiting in
queue until this time.
Then it starts service.
Next customer comes in here.
Waits in queue.
Finally starts service.
Then the system is empty.
And you integrate L of t
from here up to here.
You sum the W's.
And that's what I did
in the next slide.
And I can integrate over as many
inter-renewal periods as
you want to integrate over.
And what's going to happen?
I'm adding up these individual
inter-renewal periods.
I'm adding up this integral
over each of them.
I'm also adding up the sum of
the waiting times over that
larger interval.
And this equality
still occurs.
Any time I integrate over
an integer number of
inter-renewal periods, I have
this equality between the
integral of L of t and
the sum of W sub i's.
One of the things that we
observe from renewal theory is
when you start taking limits
between 0 and infinity, one
inter-renewal period doesn't
make any difference.
When we go on through the
mathematics there, we've done
it carefully.
We've upper bound it.
And we've lower bound it.
And we've then shown that it
doesn't make any difference.
But at this point, you know
that it doesn't make any
difference.
So that you know that when you
take the time average, the
time average number in the
system is equal to the limit
as t goes to infinity of 1 over
t times i equals 1 up to
the number of arrivals up until
time t times W sub i.
When you take that limit, it's
W sub i over A of t times the
limit of A of t over t.
Both of these go to a limit with
probability 1, because
this is just a strong law
of large numbers again.
This is just the renewal
theorem again.
And that limit here is the
time average of W. It's a
little awkward calling
this a time average.
Because what this really is
is a sample path average.
That's a sample path average
which exists
with probability 1.
This is a sample path every over
any old sample path you
want to look at of the time
average over all of the
customers that come in.
You add up all the customers
that come in and you divide by
the number of customers.
And that gives you the time
average delay that a customer
experiences.
So what Little's theorem says
is that the time average of
the expected number of customers
in the system at a
given time is equal to lambda,
which is the arrival rate--
A of t over t, is
arrival rate--
times the expected delay that
each customer experiences.
That's a very useful
relationship.
Like all of the things that come
from the Wald equality,
it only gives you a relationship
between two
things that you don't know.
But one relationship between two
things you don't know is
better than no relationships
between two
things you don't know.
Here we have this one
useful relationship.
We can understand intuitively
what's going on here if we
look this diagram again.
If you look at the diagram
again, if you expand this
whole diagram in t, if you
measure it in hours instead of
measuring it in milliseconds,
for example.
This whole thing spreads
out enormously.
And what happens?
The W's all get multiplied
by a very large amount.
A of tau stays the same.
Lambda, the expected
arrival rate,
becomes very much larger.
Arrivals per hour rather than
arrivals per millisecond.
So you see that at least as
far as scaling is scaling,
there's no way of relating this
to this without having
something there, which is
something per unit time.
This is time.
This is a time average.
So we have Little's theorem.
Useful in many, many
situations.
It's useful as an approximation
in many places
where it doesn't hold.
But the right way to look at
this, this is really an
accounting identity.
There was this first thing
we brought out, that this
integral of L of t over 1
inter-renewal period was equal
to the sum of the waiting
times over
that one renewal period.
All of the mathematics and all
of the stuff we've been
struggling with have all been
concerned with showing that
when you go to the limit as t
goes to infinity, all of these
things make sense.
Question is not whether L equals
lambda W, but whether
these quantities exist as
sensible time averages or is
limiting ensemble averages.
What we're dealing with
now is time averages.
But you can do all of these
same things with limiting
ensemble averages.
And hopefully, you get the same
answer when you do it.
And you have to go through a
lot of analysis in order to
show that these are the same.
But the idea that L is equal to
lambda W is, in some sense,
much more simple and fundamental
than that.
Last thing I want to do
is talk about the
Pollaczek-Khinchin formula
for M/G/1 queues.
The thing that you get here is
you improve on Little by one
step, because now if you have
arrivals that are coming in a
Poisson way--
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
I just have a question.
Is there an easy way to tell
when we have the condition we
need with probability
1 that restarts?
That the system empties
out with probability--
is there some kind of condition
like the expectation
of the probable [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well certainly one
thing that you want is that
the expected time between
arrivals has to be less than
the expected service time if
you only have one server.
And if you have n servers,
then you want the similar
situation that the expected
inter-arrival arrival time of
arriving customers is less than
or equal to the expected
service time divided by n.
Because you have n servers.
Now the expected arrival time
is less than or equal to n
times the expected service time
for each server, because
you have n servers working
at a time.
You have to be careful
on that one.
Because you can dream up
situations where you can have
half the servers busy
all the time.
The system never empties out.
And you always keep oscillating
between half of
the servers full and all
of the servers full.
You can even control systems
and you sometimes want to
control systems so that you have
about half the servers
operating at all time.
If you have half the servers
operating at all times, then
you have a fair amount
of leeway before
the queue fills up.
You also have a fair amount
of leeway before the queue
empties out.
And you have all these servers
that you're paying $100 an
hour to and they're not
doing anything.
So you'd like to keep, somehow,
sitting in the middle.
You would like to keep servers
busy doing other things when
they're not busy serving
customers, to
put it another way.
AUDIENCE: So there is no way
to obviously tell when the
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There is
no way in general.
For particular simple
kinds of queueing
systems, yes you can tell.
We've been going through
some of that.
For the M/G/1 queue, it's very
easy to tell, because there's
a nice formula.
And you'll see from the simple
formula that it's not as
simple as it looks.
Because first I'll tell you
what the formula is.
Suppose that X1, X2, as usual,
are IID exponential arrivals
at rate lambda.
So the arrival process
is Poisson.
That's what the M there means,
memoryless arrivals.
V1, V2, and so forth are going
to be IID service times.
We're going to assume they have
first and second moments.
First moment of the service
time, we'll call it V bar.
The second moment of the service
time, we'll call it V
squared bar.
What the Pollaczek-Khinchin
formula says is that the
expected waiting time in queue,
namely before you get
into service, expected waiting
time in queue is lambda times
V squared bar divided by 2 times
1 minus rho, where rho
is the service factor, which is
the arrival rate times the
expected service time.
This quantity here,
as the simplest
answer to your question.
If the service factor, which is
the arrival rate times the
expected service time, if that's
bigger than 1, you're
in trouble.
If that's less than 1, normally
you're not in trouble.
This formula says it's something
worse than that.
It says that as the service
factor, if the duty factor is
less than 1, this quantity
here is positive.
But if the second moment of the
service time is infinite,
you're still going to spend
an infinite amount of time
waiting in the queue.
And that's unfortunate.
You might expect this by now
after talking about residual
life on all of these things.
But it's still is unpleasant
to see it.
When you go from the expected
number in the queue to the
expected number in the
system, what is it?
Well, the expected number in the
system over time is going
to be expected number
in queue plus the
expected service time.
Yes.
A customer comes into
the system.
He waits in the queue
for a while.
Then he gets served.
This is his expected
service time.
This his expected time
waiting for service.
The expected number in this
system, how do you get that?
We get that from this by using
Little's relationship.
So the expected number in the
system is lambda squared times
V squared bar over 2
times 1 minus rho.
You multiply this
times lambda.
So you get lambda squared
from this lambda.
From the V bar, you
get lambda V bar,
which is the duty factor.
The expected number sitting in
the queue is just going to be
this quantity.
I won't derive that for you.
You can work it out.
If you look at some examples of
this, before we do try to
derive it, expected number in
a queue for an M/D/1 system,
namely Poisson arrivals,
deterministic service time.
When you have deterministic
service time, the second
moment of the service time is
just the first moment squared.
Every arrival takes you exactly
the same amount of
time to be served so that V
bar is that service time.
V bar squared is a second moment
of the service time.
So we just get the formula
we had before.
I hope it's the formula
Lambda times V bar squared.
Oh yes, rho is lambda
times V bar.
So we have lambda times
V bar squared over 2
times 1 minus rho.
You look at exponential
inter-arrivals, suddenly you
get twice as much
wait in queue.
It is worse to have exponential
service times than
it is to have Fx deterministic
service times.
If you look at this strange kind
of distribution we talked
about last time, a very, very
heavy tailed distribution in a
sense, binary distribution where
V is equal to epsilon
with probability 1
minus epsilon.
And V is equal to
1 over epsilon
with probability epsilon.
Then if you work it out, the
expected W sub q is equal to
rho over epsilon times
1 minus rho.
This is the same kind of
behavior we had before.
You have an enormous
residual life.
And therefore, the time that
you wait for a customer in
service to get finished
is very, very large.
It's what you notice all the
time if you're waiting in some
kind of system where many
of the customers
get very rapid service.
And every once in while,
there's a disaster.
A good example of this is at an
airline, when you've missed
your plane or something.
And you go up to
a booth there.
And many customers, it's
just a matter of
printing them out a ticket.
They're done in 20
or 30 seconds.
Every once in while, there's
a customer who
has enormous problems.
And it takes an hour for
them to be served.
That's exactly this
situation here.
This says that the expected
waiting time in q, before you
even get up to get your own
service has this factor of 1
over epsilon in it.
This is a nice kind formula,
because, in fact, it separates
two different kinds of things.
It has this one factor of 1 over
1 minus rho, which is a
typical factor that you get.
Because if you have a server
which is overwhelmed by too
many customers, if the average
service time is very, very
close to the average
inter-arrival time, then
you're going to have
relatively large
build ups of queues.
Every once in while,
it'll empty out.
But it will be rare.
And you're going to have a
large amount of delay.
This term here is a separate
kind of term.
And this has to do simply with
a service time distribution
that says that bad service time
distributions affect you
in exactly the same way,
no matter what
the duty factor is.
So there's this nice separation
between these two
things, which is just
the way it is.
Why does the wait in
q go up with--
that should be V squared bar.
I'm sorry.
Look at the time average weight,
the expected R of t,
for the customer in service
to finish service.
And picture of that
is down here.
If you look at this over time,
what you see is at time 0,
there's a customer that
just came in.
The residual time until it gets
finished, residual life,
is this triangle that
we're used to.
Then at this point, the next
customer starts to be served.
That time is there.
And the third customer
starts to be served.
The difference between this
and a renewal process we
looked at before, is that when
we're looking at this residual
life in a queueing system, every
once in while the queue
empties out.
And then there's a period
when nothing happens.
And then suddenly again we start
these triangles here.
So there's a question
as to how you
evaluate this time average.
Very difficult question,
isn't it?
If you had to do this in a quiz,
how would you do it?
Would you throw up your arms?
Or would you say, well let
me just figure out
what this has to be.
I have these triangles here.
I have this idle time here.
How much idle time is there?
How much triangle
time is there?
The triangles are these one half
V sub i's that we're used
to from before.
And then this empty time here
is a 1 minus rho term.
It's 1 minus the duty factor
of the system.
And that's the amount of time
over a very long period of
time, the fraction of time,
that the system is empty.
That fraction has to be 1 minus
rho, because the system
is busy with fraction rho.
It's empty with fraction
1 minus rho.
So you can write down the answer
to this without really
having much of a justification
for it.
So now we want to figure out
why this is what it is.
This is all right.
I want to take the limit as tau
goes to infinity of this
integral here over time.
And what that is going
to be is 1 over tau.
And what this is is an analytic
way of finding that
factor of 1 minus rho
that I really
didn't talk about before.
So this integral here, if I look
at it out to A of tau, is
going to be 1 over tau times
the sum of all of these
triangles here up to the number
of customers which have
arrived up until time tau.
So I have all of these out to
time tau, which is going to be
out here now.
So I sum all of these up.
And now I ask the question, what
is that sum going to be
and the limit as tau
goes to infinity?
Well, we know how to evaluate
that kind of thing, because
we've done it four or
five times already.
The limit as tau goes to
infinity of 1 over tau times
the summation from i equals
1 to A of tau Vi
squared divided by 2.
You can write this as limit of A
of tau over tau times 1 over
A of tau times the sum
from i equals 1
to A of tau Vi squared.
Now as tau increases, this A of
tau is going to increase.
These are IID random
variables.
So what we're doing is
increasing the sample average
of these IID random variables.
So this quantity goes to what?
It goes to the expected value of
V squared by the strong law
of large numbers.
And what does this
quantity go to?
A of tau over tau, that's
the number of
arrivals per unit time.
And that goes to lambda.
Is that what I got there?
I forgot this 2 here.
So that goes 1/2 expected
value of V squared.
So this is the careful way of
doing it, where you bring all
of this enormous power to bear
for something that you could
intuit without using
any of the power.
And what is W sub q then?
What is the average time
we spend in the queue?
Well you have two components
of time you
spend in the queue.
If you arrive when the server is
busy, you're going to have
to wait this residual lifetime,
which is the
expected value of r, which
is residual life.
The other thing you're going
to have to wait for is for
every customer in the
queue to be served.
Now how long does that take?
Well here you have to be quite
careful, because you have a
number of customers that have
been built up in the queue.
Each customer that's in the
queue has a service time
associated with it.
Think of a customer.
When it comes in, it's given a
little packet with its service
time in it.
So you look at the sum
of all those terms.
The question is, is the expected
number in the queue
independent of the service
time of the
customers in the queue?
And how do you reason
that out?
And at this point, you really
don't want to reason it out in
terms of writing a
lot of equations.
You want to just
think about it.
How does a queueing system work,
if you have a first come
first served queuing system?
Customers come in.
Each of them has a certain
amount of time to be served,
which it's holding in a little
bag at its side, but which
nobody else sees.
And these are independent,
random variables.
But when it comes in, there
are a certain number of
customers in the queue
in front of it.
So the number of customers that
are in the queue before
it each have their own service
times sitting in their own
little pockets.
So the amount of time that it
takes for me to be served is
this sum of all of the
previous times.
And all these previous
times are
independent, random variables.
And each of them are independent
of how many
customers are in the queue
at the time they arrive.
So what I'm trying to argue is
that the number of customers
in the queue at time t are
independent of the service
time of each of those customers,
because the service
times are not apparent to the
system until a person getting
into service takes it out of his
pocket and looks at what
his service time is.
And that's unknown
to the system
until the service starts.
So when you take N q bar
independent of V bar0--
Incidentally, if you read the
notes, this is explained in a
slightly more mathematical than
customers having little
pockets which they read.
But it doesn't help
a whole lot.
But anyway, when you go through
that argument, you
then get this expression.
And then you add a
little Little.
Namely a little Little's
theorem, which says that N sub
q is equal to lambda
times W sub q.
So you can take this over
on the other side.
And this gives you lambda
V squared over 2,
which is this term.
And at the same time,
you get 1 over--
Excuse me.
Lambda V squared over
2 is this term.
And W q minus N q V bar is
1 minus is W q times 1--
I'll do it at the board.
Probably I'll see it.
But W sub q is equal to lambda
V squared over 2.
That's the expected value of
r plus lambda W sub Q bar.
So we take this over
on this side.
And then we get W q bar equals
lambda V squared over 2 times
1 over 1 minus lambda.
1 minus lambda V bar.
Where did the V bar come from?
Beats me.
Oh, came from this
quantity there.
Let's patch up our lambda
V bar times W sub q bar.
So now we get lambda V bar.
That is all I had
to say today.
And so have any questions?